we hope you've got health insurance
because we're about to blow your minds
those who have seen 2017 spider-man
homecoming and his 2019 sequel
spider-man far from home will remember
Roger Harrington the slightly dorky more
than slightly bumbling while meaning
science teacher played by Martin Starr
in homecoming mr. Harrington instructs
the students of midtown school of
Science and Technology and oversees the
school's academic decathlon team of
which Tom Hollands Peter Parker is a
member and in far from home the teacher
tries his hardest to make a student's
summer trip across Europe as wonderful
as possible but proves hilariously
incompetent to be fair it's not entirely
his fault mr. Harrington is a memorable
MCU character but homecoming and far
from home on the only Marvel movies he's
been in a several sharp-eyed fans have
pointed out mr. Harrington made his MCU
debut way back in 2008 when he cameoed
in the Incredible Hulk which despite
what your one friend might insist is
indeed part of the MCU remember the
student who smiles and waves a slice of
pizza at Edward Norton's Bruce Banner in
the chemistry lab at Culver University
yeah that's Roger Harrington credited in
the film's simply as computer nerd
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige
confirmed the fact during a AMA session
on reddit one fan Rose Martin star was
both in the Incredible Hulk very briefly
in the computer lab and in spider-man
homecoming as Peter Parker's debate
coach can we assume these are the same
people
Feige replied with a simple observation
saying quote I do it makes sense that
the book smart student became a not so
street smart teacher and a science
teacher of that it also makes sense that
a character from an old film was
retconned into also being a character in
a newer film considering Marvel also did
that very thing with Peter Parker and
the young man dressed as Iron Man at the
end of Iron Man 2
so Phi Keys Confirmation makes us a nice
bit of Marvel trivia to share at your
next dinner party
however the admission that stars
character for me Incredible Hulk and the
spider-man movies are the same person
arguably puts a tiny wrinkle in the
overall Marvel Canon particularly
regarding a tie-in novel that
accompanied the release of The
Incredible Hulk as many fans have noted
the Incredible Hulk novelization takes a
different approach to the character star
played in the film identifying him as
being a korean-american genius named
Amadeus Cho who was first introduced in
Marvel Comics in 2005 since star is
definitely not korean-american like Cho
is the two characters are more like
analogues to one another than anything
else but we digress in the novel version
of the story Banner meets show when he
sneaks into the computer lab finding the
students studying for his final exams
much like movie bana does with martin
stars character bana offers chosen pizza
and that's the end of that a scene like
this was actually supposed to be
included in the movie as an extended
version of stars actual scene in the
final film the deleted scene sees bana
trying to trick his way into the lab
with the promise of free pizza with the
excuse that someone in the radiation lab
called for it and then bailed the tactic
works like a charm
getting Banner easy access to use the
computer and search for the data he
needs you my friend are a hero
interestingly enough the Cho character
referenced in a novelization actually
ended up with a meaty role in Marvel
Comics years later going on to succeed
banner as the Hulk as the star of the
2015 comic series the totally awesome
Hulk the connection between Martin stars
Incredible Hulk character and the books
Amadeus Cho is pretty undeniable but
since Feige has since stated that a
computer nerd in the Incredible Hulk
movie is actually Roger Harrington that
means he's not armored Deus Chow so in
case you were wondering that means that
the Incredible Hulk novelization
officially isn't canonical this isn't to
say that Marvel fans weren't ever see
Cho in the MCU one day becoming the J
genius after banner somehow passes a
torch he just probably won't be played
by Martin Starr as you know we made it
out alive and that's the important thing
I couldn't bear to lose a student on a
school trip not again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and at the Bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]